now just like we have been telling you
joe biden the democrats socialists are
on a shameless pursuit of power
they are now unleashing what is the
single most destructive agenda in modern
political history
it started with destroying american
energy jobs while
wanting to spend you know trillions and
trillions on the green new deal
then they opened up the southern border
and took aim at american sovereignty
ignoring our laws ignoring our borders
and our security
then they moved to pack the court and
today on a party line vote
house democrats rammed through their
bill to make washington d.c the 51st
state
which by the way might want to refresh
their memory that would be
unconstitutional without an amendment
now and next on the daca for democrats
massive tax hikes reparations
and abolishing the senate filibuster
which joe biden claims now is racist
but on the campaign trail he said he
would do
none of these things take a look
speaking of those other candidates
several of them have proposed
major structural reforms to our
government and to our democracy these
include
abolishing the electoral college
expanding the size of the supreme court
setting term limits for justices
abolishing the legislative filibuster
which
if any of these do you support none
because that structural change requires
constitutional amendments it grazes
problems that are more
damaging than the problems exist
well now that joe's claiming racism was
he
by definition in that tape during the
campaign
was he being a racist because remember
biden didn't have any issue with the
filibuster
when democrats were using it to block
republican legislation
and while joe biden keeps talking about
quote systemic racism
when is joe going to be held accountable
for his record of
racial rhetoric you know warning the
country about becoming a quote
racial jungle back in 1977
working with the former klansmen the guy
that filibustered the civil rights act
the voting rights act
and stood against integration of our
schools
when is there going to be accountability
for the decades of
democratic and specifically joe biden
systemic racism because tonight it
couldn't be
any more clear that democrats empower
they want it in perpetuity
they want power at all costs they do not
like checks they do not like balances
they do not like co-equal branches of
government
and they don't seem to care about the
integrity of institutions that have
served this country well
for years not making necessary changes
when needed that's not what we're
talking about
they do not care about working class
families they certainly don't give a
damn about freedoms and
constitutionally protected rights they
think they could just get rid of them
with the stroke of a pet
so who are the republicans who of them
are going to stand up to this power grab
and who in the republican party will
fight for the trump agenda to make
america great again
agenda and fight against the d.c sewer
in swamp
one name generating a lot of chatter in
the state of ohio is venture capitalist
author of hillbilly elergy jd vance is
with us
and he's joined along with nationally
syndicated radio
talk show host larry elder jd let's talk
about
joe during the campaign and joe now
yeah you know one of the things that joe
during the campaign revealed is that all
this talk about systemic
racism is very often just a facade to
give democrats power they're not going
to go back and criticize anything that
joe biden has said
because now that he's the president they
can use his power to enhance their
ability
to always win elections always stay in
power always stack the constitutional
deck against the right
and you know there's a there's a sick
part of me that thinks that the
democrats
actually know what they're doing because
they when they get power they want to
use it
they want to perpetuate it they want to
ensure that they stay in power
forever and their capacity to use the
levers of
of government to do that you know again
there's a sick part of me that almost
admires their willingness to do what
they say that they're going to
do and even go beyond that even though i
think it's terrible for our country
you know if you look at you know dc
stater larry elder many people may not
know i
know you're a lawyer by trade
other states cannot be admitted without
an amendment to our constitution am i
wrong or right on that sir
um as if sean is if they care
you know the last time we admitted two
states they were alaska
and hawaii and the reason that was
doable is because both parties could
come to an agreement because
it was expected that one state would be
republican and one state would be
democrat
and it was in this case if
d.c became a state and then ultimately
puerto rico which is next next on the
docket
it would produce four new republican
senators and two new republican house
members and democrats still wanted to do
it
i would believe them when they say that
they're doing this because they want
these people
to have representation same thing with
illegal immigration
if the pathway to citizenship that would
turn 22 million illegal aliens
into voters if two-thirds of them would
vote republican sean
i would believe that when they say they
want these people to quote come out of
the shadows
this is as mr vance just now said all
about
power and i would think that even some
moderates don't want a doubling of the
minimum wage
some moderates don't want the corporate
tax rate to increase because they
benefit
from the trump economy some moderates on
the democrat side don't agree with this
climate change alarmism so these voices
are going to be silenced
as well as the republican voices so i'm
just saying to all of these moderate
democrats
look in the mirror because you are next
they're going to cancel you if you don't
go along with that hardcore
left-wing agenda yeah last word
do you believe the 50 republicans will
stand together to fight
and walk out of the senate if necessary
to prevent a quorum
if they try to remove the legislative
filibuster
mr vance i'll ask you you know sean
you know sean i really hope that they
will i think there are a couple of
republicans that are probably wavering
but at the end of the day the
republicans need to recognize in the
senate if they don't take a stand now
they're going to lose their ability to
govern on any of the issues that we care
about into the future they've got to
stand up
and fight right now yeah all right thank
you both uh are you running for senate
last question any chance i'll let you
know i'll let you know if i do
why i never get a straight answer larry
you're a talk why why don't we ever get
the direct answer i'm kidding
all right thank you hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else